para los residentes de mico life esto
ahora es parte de la vida diaria la
ciudad del sur de ucrania ha estado sin
agua durante más de dos semanas la
guerra destruyó la infraestructura que
traía al flujo desde la cercana región
de gerson que ahora está mayormente
ocupada por rusia
tengo que ir a buscar agua todos los
días por supuesto que quiero que las
cosas mejoren esta no es una situación
normal para un país europeo estas son
nuestras tierras no atacamos a nadie no
hemos dañado a nadie muy bonito que le
emocione normal es
un gran problema es para las personas
que físicamente no pueden ir a buscar
agua por si mismas y que están atrapadas
en sus casas las personas mayores las
personas discapacitadas así que estamos
tratando de conseguir agua tanto para
nosotros como para las personas mayores
que no pueden llevarse
detrás del muro está la fuente de agua
uno de los 11 pozos que las autoridades
de mykolaiv han excavado alrededor de la
ciudad en un esfuerzo por dar suministro
a los habitantes
los pozos por sí solos no son
suficientes y a pesar de que casi la
mitad de la población se ha ido por los
bombardeos rusos se están realizando
esfuerzos para llevar agua en convoyes a
la ciudad asediada en toda la localidad
las colas son constantes en los puntos
de distribución algunas empresas
privadas se han unido a los esfuerzos
oficiales en solidaridad como nos contó
un conductor de una compañía de
transportes
y
tenemos al bueno de esa ni aquí en
mykolaiv no hay nada todos aguantan lo
mejor que pueden así que creo que
tenemos que ayudar a la gente no vivimos
lejos unos de otros
el alcalde de nicolaides sospecha que
rusia puede haber apuntado a la
infraestructura de agua con un objetivo
en mente
[Música]
para crear un problema con la ecología o
algo así el ministerio de defensa de
rusia escribió en su sitio web que hay
un problema en mykolaiv mucha gente está
muriendo por enfermedades causadas por
la falta de agua
por ahora los residentes de mykolaiv
siguen mostrando un sentido de profunda
solidaridad las autoridades buscan
restaurar el servicio de agua durante al
menos unas pocas horas cada día pero
también están exhortando a las personas
para que se vayan de la ciudad ante el
peligro de nuevos bombardeos rusos